We're here tonight to celebrate the career of a brilliant young man comedian
actor, artist magician,
and some would say a smooth print out player from the streets that knows how to
get his. Please welcome. I want you to check this.
God is he's very funny. If he's from Washington,
DC and the Grammy goes to bring to you now.
Dave Chappelle written by Dave.
I haven't seen.
Have a seat, man. That's all relaxed. Thanks for coming back.
Since you guys have been so good to me tonight, I feel like I owe, you know,
this, this next piece is about the real Dave Chappelle's personal.
It's actually very personal, but here it is,
that was around midnight. I was playing that's a Thelonious monk song.
One of my favorite musicians, because his timing was so ill.
Every comedian is a stickler for timing and the loneliest monk was off
time. Yet, perfectly on time, you should study it.
You're an aspiring comedian or aspiring musician. He's just.
Right.
I was going through a real tough time, man, like just readjusting.
And uh,
my mom bought me this time magazine with bill Cosby on the cover because
the ink, me and the guy had a lot of stuff in common.
Like some of the quotes he would say. And I just remember, like,
after reading this stuff, I put it down and it was like,
I'm a be a comedic every time there's a blur celebrity in trouble.
Nails of the belief that I never think he's guilty.
And the reason he thinks that is because I never think they're guilty.
It's just how I roll man. At first, I didn't believe. And I was like, man,
these people are obviously trying to destroy Dr. Cosby's rich legacy.
When, uh, Cosby got sentenced Chappelle and rod call me back to back.
Like both of them legitimately sad.
I felt bad.
For them. I was explaining some of my younger family members,
you know who I like who he was at one point juxtapose to
what's happening now. So it's astounding.
Obviously bill constantly was a hero to me and she doesn't know what it feels
like to think that your hero might've done something so heinous, all my heroes,
either murdered by the government registered sections.
My wife would probably be like.
Oh my God, Dave, look, there's George.
Washington's the father of this great nation. I'm going to go shake his hand.
I'd be on the other side. Like.
Ron, George Washington.
It's tough to see your heroes fall,
let alone be a villain because he wrote the declaration of
independence and all that. We hold these truths to be self-evident Oh,
man.
Are created equal.
Go get me a sandwich. I'll kill you. Justice for him.
This is my impression of the founding fathers of America.
When the constitution was being written, hurry up,
you finished that constitution. I'm trying to get some sleep.
White people. Does it take the screw on the line? I don't know.
Cause they'll get them negative dude for him.
And now you know how comedy is, right?
You always talk about whatever is close to your mind. It's like the trick lady,
man joke is just something that's painful to me that you just try to make fun of
drugs. And alcohol have ruined my life.
We started talking about bratty shows.
We want to do something that was real personal. It was just, I don't know.
It just, the word personal kept coming up.
I started doing drugs when I was little, just like you.
I grew up in the crack epidemic. I tell jokes about it. I lived in the eighties.
It was, it was not like this in the eighties.
It was like a crack bomb had gone off like,
like DC during the crack epidemic was probably one of the worst cities in
America. Everybody I knew so cracks. I only,
God knows how many people were smoking crack.
That made a real big impression on crack head trying to break into somebody's
car, man. And it struck a chord with me. I tried.
Stop. I said, Hey. And he looked back and saw me and said, keep an eye out.
I'm trying to help you. I want the to stop.
And now there's opioid epidemic. Are they treating the opioid epidemic?
The way that they treated the crack epidemic? No,
this is a national health emergency.
When we were coming up with police by the national guard,
addicts were criminals. It was like a little suspicious.
There's a little suspicious.
Every dead black person and police fan has crack sprinkled on them.
These white folks look exactly like us during the crack epidemic.
So now that your community is getting destroyed is the whole nother ball game.
It's a huge window of empathy, Tyrone.
You know, I love you, but I feel like drugs is hurting you and it hurt me.
Y'all wanna party with us.
There we go. Here comes to deep water. This is.
I shouldn't even say it's not politically correct to say these things.
I'm going to say something that I'm not allowed to say. I know it sounds up.
I'm not supposed to say that. I'm going to get canceled for
think people paying money,
to see a guy speak precisely and carefully.
Most likely you have a responsibility to speak records.
He's a comedian who's kind of to jab.
The lion, you know, who is trying to.
Test the waters way back on the second episode, I did this piece about the, uh,
a crack addict coming to a, a drug awareness week at a school.
I got a lot of complaints about it. I got a lot of letters about it.
A lot of people said I was insensitive.
So I brought them back again to the show. If you say to a comedian,
you can't do this. I guarantee you,
they will immediately do it tonight. Musical guests,
two in Chicago's finest, Sam, see, give it up for comment. And Kanye West,
I walked in the crib, got two kids and my baby mama
[inaudible] musicians were like this.
Every comic wants to be a musician.
Every musician thinks they're funny.
It's a very strange relationship in your head.
All these people who we all have in common,
I think we all have personal message that they try to get across. First of all,
Kanye is the artist and he's a genius. I've known Dan for a long time.
He's a genius. He's a real comedy genius. Yes.
I think that the angle he's seeing things from is about the vision that he sees
and all this they talk about on the news about how divided the nation is.
I love them. I support them. And if you at home watching this on Netflix,
remember, you clicked on my face.
I don't have to agree with everything that he says. I just,
I just trust him as a person of intent. But, uh, yeah,
he shouldn't say all that, but I, for one find solace in the arts.
I don't have to agree with all the arc and Sue,
but it helps me understand how I actually feel about it.
19, the champion is the youngest comedian to ever appear on star search.
He's from Washington DC. Here's Dave Chapelle.
[inaudible] thank you guys, man.
When I'm on stage, I get real happy up there.
Like maybe that's the only time in my adult life that I feel like myself
standing up there. You know what I mean?
Like gladiator and then likes is on him and you look down and everyone's looking
at,
and it's all of these smiles around you and they get dressed or put
perfume on and stuff. And they're going to see your show. It's the best feeling,
man. I love standing.
That's why I love my obstacle because I understand every practitioner,
whether I grew with them or not. I know where they're coming from.
They want to be heard. They got something to say,
there's something they noticed. They just want to be. I love this job.
It's saved my life. These people are at least as influential to me.
As my family, we fight the fuss, jealous of each other.
We get mad at each other,
but my life wouldn't have been what it was without each and every one of them,
I, those will always be my. Cause I grew up with them.
It was way bigger than hip hop. That's like kind of like that was our work.
Those my life. I grew up with them cause we was like this.
So nothing never come between them. You know what I'm saying?
You're watching this. I appreciate that Justin. And I want you to know,
everybody. Dave Chappelle understands.
It's always a really gratifying experience making these videos that take a more
documentary and look at a single artist, whether it's Chappelle Quintin,
Tarantino, or Bo Burnham, delving into an artist's body of work,
always provides a window into their soul. It's also why I love Dan Dan Lee,
his class creating a modern cinematic documentary with soul.
It's an invaluable guide to crafting a story out of someone's life experience.
For me, it alone made my Skillshare membership worth it.
Skillshare has catalog of thousands of classes in film, business technology,
and more make being a member, a no brainer, no matter what your interests are,
but see for yourself right now,
you can get two months of Skillshare for free with our link,
click the link in the description and get two months of unlimited access to
thousands of classes for free.
Plus it helps us to at no cost to you and as always thanks to our patrons who
make this channel possible. Thanks for watching.